♪♪
-I was on the phone with
one of the major airlines
trying to get back
into my account
'cause I couldn't remember
the password.
So I finally get through --
-You're on
the Intelligence Committee.
I just want --
The president doesn't like you.
-I'm all cinnamon, nutmeg,
allspice.
-And I'm working on my biceps,
you know, like,
just going like this.
-I felt the Schweddy Balls
would give it away.
-Oh, yeah.
-We don't go to school.
-Ooooh.
-Oh, my God.
-Who's gonna use the word "limn"
in a sketch?
-We wanted them to add kids to
the cast of "SNL" at one point
and have, like, a little update
that they would cut to,
so they'd go from Seth and Amy
to two kids, remember?
And Lorne was like,
"We're not doing that."
-Each job, you learn
the most just rogue skill set
that you're like, "Oh, I didn't
know I needed to know this."
And on that one, I was like,
"Oh, theme-park acting."
There's this art to it.
You literally --
You have to wave like that.
And you have to react
all the time.
Ooh!
-I had prosthetic makeup help
from, like,
the genius makeup artist.
He's the man who won an Oscar
for making up Gary Oldman
as Winston Churchill.
-There you go.
-At the very moment when I was
playing Winston Churchill
with no makeup at all.
-Yeah.
-Turns out I look
a lot like Winston Churchill.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I don't need
any witnesses at all.
-Okay, and then --
-I am ready to go.
I'm not trying to pretend
to be a fair juror here.
-Lindsey Graham sounds like a
dude who's just making stuff up
to get out of jury duty.
"I can't serve on a jury.
My grandma's sick,
and I'm her caretaker.
And I'm cat-sitting.
I live far away.
And I don't speak English,
and I'm biased against cops."
My favorite line from Trump's
insane letter is this --
"Since the moment
I won the election,
the Democratic Party has been
possessed by impeachment fever."
"Impeachment fever" sounds like
he's narrating an old newsreel
about The Beatles
landing in America.
Impeachment fever
is sweeping the nation.
Look at the throngs of teenagers
screaming
as they greet the Fab Four --
Pelosi, Schumer, Schiff,
and don't forget the dumb one,
Donald.
Uh-oh, looks like he's having
trouble with his umbrella again.
-It's a snowman,
and it says "Merry Christmas."
-Uh-huh.
-And I asked them to put "Seth"
on the hat.
-Yeah.
-I'm sorry.
I should have gone to
the Cake Boss and got a real --
[ Laughter ]
-This is a really good cake.
-Here it goes. Watch out.
-Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
-I think they should start
making Hallmark holiday movies
with lesbian leads.
How fun would that be?
"Deck the Halls" --
two female carpenters get hired
to build a deck
the week before Christmas.
But instead of a deck,
they end up building a bridge
to each other.
"All I Want for Christmas
Is Sue" --
a woman is hopelessly in love
with her straight co-worker Sue,
so she writes Santa a letter
asking him to make Sue gay.
And Santa does it.
[ Laughter ]
Then there's
"Thanks for Nothing, Santa,"
a sequel told from Sue's
husband's perspective.
-Watched "Grey's Anatomy"
and thought,
"Oh, I'm gonna be a doctor."
-Just because of Sandra Oh
playing one on TV?
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-It's an example
of bad representation
because it tricks Asian people
into going into
the medical field.
-Have you waxed before?
-No.
-Okay.
-This all just happens
on its own.
-Alright.
♪♪